[Music]
I'm Rahul Pandey I run my operations out
of India I'm a Founder CEO of of an
Enterprise SAS company Bonsai one of the
biggest challenges brands are going to
have is to scale their creative content
that was a point when I started to think
how might we take this Challenge and
give a solution through a technology to
scale our customers across Asia we are
in Australia New Zealand Singapore and
the other parts of Southeast Asia that's
the thing which really motivates me
drives me to work with this incredible
team to go along and build something
awesome and build it for the world this
is my third engagement with Stanford The
Learning in sap is multi-fold at
individual level at organization level
and the society level I learned a lot
about leadership I learned a lot about
how do you become a successful leader
leading a global team how do you work
across different culture how do use
different Frameworks to drive the
efficiency Innovation that's been an
amazing learning at the organizational
level this is a process of unlearning
and I realized there are many areas
where you need to re-look into process
people thinking I think each of the
faculty members are Masters in their
area so to me every Professor I met they
are my superheroes you know they are
inspiring me to go and change the world
I feel more confident as a leader I feel
more energetic and charged up to go and
and get Bonsai to the world
foreign
[Music]